ja also deutschland hat den teuersten
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk der welt
und ich sag mal wir sparen jetzt überall
sonst wir müssen sonst überall opfer
bringen das ding ist zu teuer zu träge
und vor allem auch zu links stefan
müller der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der csu hat deswegen
jetzt gefordert mit blick auf die
galoppierende inflation dass man doch
mal drei monate auf den rundfunkbeitrag
so zu sagen dass man ihn aussetzen
könnte ich sage eigentlich das geht
nicht weit genug wir müssen an den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk mal ganz
grundlegend dran
es drei monate pausieren oder gar nicht
findet jetzt schräg ja man verfolgt eine
agenda den öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk möglich abzuschaffen und nutzt
jetzt die tatsache dass wir es mit
inflation mit steigenden
lebenshaltungskosten zu tun haben und
sogar noch auto zu fahren als er schon
großes problem also ich bin sehr für
entlastung vor allem der geringeren
einkommens macht ja ein unterschied ob
nur die eigene sparquote etwas sinkt
oder ob es wirklich ans eingemachte geht
dass man miete oder lebensmittel kaum
noch zahlen kann oder das benzin für die
pendler da gibt es aber andere
möglichkeiten ja von einer energie
pauschale für sie ist der öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk hat seine
daseinsberechtigung sollte jetzt auch
nicht ja für mich ist das habe ich
rechtliche rundfunk bei aller kritik die
ich auch daran habe das ist eine
institution der demokratie sorry und die
sollte möglichst
staatsfernsehen hier gefällt überhaupt
nicht dass da lauter ministerpräsidenten
und abgeordneten in den rundfunkräten
sitzen sollte möglichst realistisch sein
und sollte auch sparsam sein natürlich
ist der öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk
muss man nicht drumrumreden
sich hypertrophe also der der ist über
seine maßen
immer neue programme immer neue sender
das muss nicht sein soll sich
konzentrieren auf seinen informations-
und bildungsauftrag aber dass wir einen
nichtkommerziellen medienbereich haben
das finde ich eine demokratische
errungenschaft darf ich da noch ein
bisschen drauf entgegnen also jetzt den
anlass von stefan müller zu nehmen mit
den preisen das ist einfach eine reale
geschichte wir müssen jetzt einfach mal
bei ganz vielen geschichten überlegen wo
kann man da was kürzen und öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk ist auch eine
institution wo man sparen kann so das
aber jetzt nur als trigger prinzipiell
müssen wir uns schon die frage stellen
wie wollen wir den öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk eigentlich in
zukunft gestalten weil in seiner
jetzigen form ist nicht mehr zeitgemäß
das ist ein konstrukt der frühen 60er
jahre wie heute dass es gibt
doppelstrukturen damit das mal gehört
haben neun landesrundfunkanstalten
74 radiosender je nach zählweise da kann
man sich nicht darauf einigen 12 bis 21
öffentlich rechtliche
fernsehsender alle haben eine eigene
zentralverwaltung leitung personal
rechte vermarktung einkauf
aufsichtsgremium et cetera pp herr
sozusagen beim wdr intendant tom buhrow
400.000 jahresgehalt beim bayerischen
rundfunk ebenfalls selbst der kleine
saarländische rundfunk hat der intendant
250.000 euro da kann ich doch als ich
jetzt mal ganz im ernst das sind doch
summen da träumt doch jeder normale
private fernsehsender von und das ist
einfach nicht mehr zeitgemäß da kann man
wirklich jetzt mal zurückfahren und kann
mal sagen wir kürzen dass auf die hälfte
oder dergleichen wir können auch mal zur
bbc schauen ja die bbc hat in
großbritannien einen etat von 4,8
milliarden der bei uns 9,1 das ist die
hälfte also grob so ich würde nicht
sagen dass die bbc ein schlechteres
nachrichtenangebot liefert als ard und
zdf wenn ich mir die ukraine
berichterstattung anschaue muss ich
sagen tendenziell eine schlechtere die
visier hat natürlich weniger
spartenprogramme und kaka hat ganz eine
ganz andere einnahmequellen weil sie die
die politischen programme lassen sich
auf der ganzen welt verkaufen sie können
jetzt sie können den den also bis auf
derrick oder was kann man sehr wenig von
dem dach oder kann man sehr wenig was in
deutschland produziert international
verkaufen wie sie es natürlich auch ein
riesiges land produzieren als auch der
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk hat ja
auch schon stoffe verkauft jetzt aus
natürlich nicht ich habe den anderen maß
als ein sender der auf der ganzen welt
schon lange wege sprache verkaufen
verstehst du denn das vorhaben alexander
oder die idee wenn man sie 236 super ich
würde jetzt mal annehmen dass es hier
möglich gesamte zu tanzen aber für viele
menschen bestimmt auch verdient denn
dann können auch gedanken aber für viele
menschen ist es ja wirklich dass sie
über autofahrten auch nachdenken wie
würdest du das denn einschätzen das
vorhaben mal drei morde zu pausieren und
vielleicht auch als öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk ein zeichen zu
setzen ich glaube das ist ein tropfen
auf den heißen stein gemacht wie macht
die preissteigerung enorme die sorge ich
glaube dass die inflation im moment
haben ist wirklich ist die höchst
gefährdend für für niedrige und mittlere
einkommen dass wir steuern auf eine auf
eine nationale übrigens nation
wirtschaftskrise alterssicherung ist
wenn heute alle gratis die leute die
etwa kleine gewerbetreibende meine
eltern hatten zu geschäft denn sie
hatten keine rentenversicherung die
waren darauf angewiesen zu sparen und
rücklagen für das alter zu bilden und
die werden gerade massiv entwertet ich
habe ja mal ein buch geschrieben die
kunst des stilvollen verarmen und habe
dabei wird vorausgesagt dass wir alle
ärmer werden das sieht ja dass ich da
dass ich tatsächlich meinen prophezeien
von den weg jetzt war er weiß hätte ich
nicht gedacht es ist tatsächlich so dass
wir auf eine dass wir alle
wahrscheinlich in zukunft auf die zeiten
der 80er 90er jahre als
paradiesisch zurückschauen wenn wir
werden uns alle sehr viel mehr
einschränken das liegt aber auch daran
dass wir viele kosten wie die ökonomen
sagen ausgelagert haben externalisierung
wir haben klimakosten ausgelagert und
wir haben sicherheitskosten ausgelagert
jetzt müssen wir den preis dafür
bezahlen
ich finde ich finde das letzte sagte
echt wichtig obwohl sein die laune
verdirbt das mache ich jetzt mal ganz
kurz ich sehe dieses kann die ganze
preis debatte die wir jetzt führen die
lebenshaltungskosten alles möglich ist
natürlich das pendel weit ausgeschlagen
in die richtung aber die richtung bleibt
also ich glaube das leben wird so wie
wir es leben wollen ich sage auch noch
dazu bisschen angespitzt so wie wir das
leben sollen politisch gewollt teurer
werden und das kann ja ein guter grund
sein weil sonst dann länger gut geht auf
dieser welt aber die menschen den
menschen klar zu machen dass es so wie
in den nuller jahren nicht mehr werden
wird das finde ich auch eine wichtige
funktion der politik insofern finde ich
schon richtig drauf zu gucken wo man
vielleicht geld her holen kann
aber nicht darüber hinwegzutäuschen
dass unser leben in der zukunft aufgrund
der film vielen dinge die wir
geschrieben haben teurer werden wird
allein ich meine jeder ihre eltern im
showgeschäft hätten doch nicht lange
rechnen müssen nach wie viele milliarden
bei corona nach soviel milliarden für
den krieg in dessen ende nicht absehbar
ist nach sowieso einer
staatsverschuldung und nach dem ausbau
auf ein völlig neuer energieformen und
und und und und dann kommt er jetzt kein
schuhverkäufer auf die idee dass alles
so bleibt wie jetzt sondern kommen große
dinge auf uns zu und ich sage ich jetzt
mal ein bisschen despektierlich ihr
politiker tut gut daran wenn er die
menschen früh genug damit nimmt er auf
diese reise
wenn sie zustimmen gilt dies auch für
unsere diskussion von über den ukraine
krieg ja der bundeskanzler hat
eigentlich nach seiner berühmten
zeitenwende rede dann wieder
zurückgerudert und versucht die leute zu
beruhigen die eigentlich gar nicht
halten wollte die zeit zu beruhigen
wollte eigentlich gar nicht brauchen so
wir halten diesen krieg von euch weg und
das ist
keine politische finden ich habe noch
eine frage freuen sich denn eigentlich
die grünen jetzt über die steigenden
spritpreise war eigentlich wollten die
grünen ja auch das bedeutet
also was die grünen ich bin ja kein
parteisprecher und auch nicht mehr aktiv
in der besagten aber mitglied wegen der
ökologischen frage und es stimmt schon
dass die grünen sagen wir sollen hier
sich den sprit subventionieren weil das
ist gut wenn der teurer wird dann wird
weniger gefahren oder man steigt um auf
öffentliche verkehrsmittel da wo das
möglich ist sondern wir sollten niedrige
einkommen entlasten indem man den eine
energie pauschale zahlt damit sie ihre
energiekosten sagen decken können aber
nicht am preis rummachen der preis hat
in der marktwirtschaft eine wichtige
steuerungsfunktion
forderung ich habe jetzt aber das sind
sie doch sagt mission der
computerhersteller
euro gleich